[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas el pasado 24 de junio
las fuerzas paramilitares rusas de
Wagner bajo el mando de Jean y pregosing
iniciaron una sorpresiva rebelión contra
la cúpula militar rusa Los mercenarios
amenazaban con avanzar hasta Moscú pero
dieron media vuelta tras un pacto
mediado por el presidente bielorruso
Alexander lucashenko Vladimir Putin
tildó el hecho como una puñalada por la
espalda sin embargo optó por retirar la
investigación criminal contra y por no
perseguir a Quienes participaron del
levantamiento la muestra de
inestabilidad política y militar en
Rusia ha dejado preocupada la comunidad
internacional pero también a los
ciudadanos rusos que tras el inicio de
la Guerra de Ucrania se refugiaron en
Francia France 24 fue a su encuentro
para conocer sus impresiones de lo
ocurrido que les traemos en el siguiente
informe de cleapacaná
hacer muñecos de Vladimir Putin en forma
de bailarinas es una forma de activismo
para Katia
es como un recuerdo para demostrar que
Putin es una figura lamentable
no da miedo en absoluto
ella siguió de cerca los acontecimientos
en Rusia en particular los avances del
grupo Wagner en el sur del país y luego
su repentina retirada
era obvio que algo así iba a ocurrir
que estallaría un conflicto entre este
grupo criminal Porque nuestro país está
gobernado por bandidos
forman un gran grupo criminal organizado
y los conflictos iban a estallar
se mudó a París hace un año con su hijo
arsénix de 17 años como artista y
activista política corría Peligro en
Moscú y le preocupaba que arseni pudiera
ser llamado a las filas del ejército
ruso
su marido Denis y su hija de 23 años
Sasha se unieron a ellos unos meses
después
se sienten Afortunados de haber
encontrado seguridad en Francia pero las
noticias de la rebelión del grupo Wagner
reavivaron sus preocupaciones por su
familia y amigos en casa
por supuesto estábamos asustados
pensamos que una vez más iba a morir
gente pero yo estaba seguro de una cosa
que no iba a matar a Putin y pues yo
también
ya
toda mi vida Putin ha sido presidente no
conozco formas de vida alternativas
diseño gráfico y está a punto de empezar
un nuevo trabajo en Francia
Rusia tiene una cultura muy rica y hay
muchos grandes proyectos de arte
contemporáneo pero hoy en día no puedo
hacer planes a largo plazo porque todo
cambia muy deprisa
mientras Rusia prosigue su guerra contra
Ucrania y su familia como los miles de
rusos que han llegado recientemente a
Francia viven día a día sin poder volver
a casa por ahora
fueron varios días de intensas búsquedas
en las profundidades del Océano
Atlántico en su superficie y también
desde el aire pero las autoridades
encontraron restos del sumergible titán
de la compañía Ocean Gate llegando a la
Inevitable conclusión de que los cinco
pasajeros a bordo en la misión que
buscaba explorar y visitar las ruinas
del Titanic murieron como consecuencia
de una implosión catastrófica de la nave
la historia cautivó la atención
mediática del mundo y hoy todas las
miradas se centran sobre Ocean Gate pues
durante mucho tiempo fueron varias las
voces que expresaron su preocupación por
motivos de seguridad veamos el siguiente
informe de
el titán se sumergía casi 4.000 metros
bajo el mar en el entorno más hostil del
planeta sin embargo este sumergible era
prácticamente de fabricación artesanal
no estaba certificado y ya había hecho
sonar varias alarmas el creador del
titán era el
ceo de la empresa Ocean Gate que murió
con el resto de los pasajeros Este es el
único sumergible de aguas profundas
equipado con baño
hace un año mostraba con orgullo su
creación el sumergible más espacioso de
su tipo jamás diseñado para avanzar se
presiona aquí para retroceder subir o
bajar es muy fácil pero la empresa
estaba atravesando una serie de
conflictos internos en 2018 este
director de operaciones marítimas de
Ocean Gate renunció preocupado Según
dijo por los peligros potenciales para
los pasajeros el principal objeto de
preocupaciones era el ojo de buey que
solo estaba aprobado para inmersiones a
metros tres veces menos que la
profundidad del Titanic un millonario
británico iba a participar en la última
inmersión del titán aquel fin de semana
pero cambió de opinión debido al diseño
de la nave utilizaron viejos postes de
andamio como lastre del sumergible es el
tipo de cosas que uno hace para
atravesar un río con dos pedazos de
Cuerda pero no me lo esperaba en
absoluto para una nave comercial que se
suponía iba a descender varias veces a
grandes profundidades así que me retiré
de la misión
hace ya cinco años cerca de 30
profesionales de la exploración marítima
compartieron las mismas Preocupaciones
en una carta dirigida al fabricante del
submarino
nos preocupa que el enfoque experimental
adoptado por el Ocean Gate provoque
Consecuencias negativas de menores a
catastróficas los principales motivos de
preocupación eran la forma y el material
del casco que nunca había sido
certificado
era la primera vez que la cabina no era
esférica sino cilíndrica y hecha de
fibra de carbono así que no se tenía ni
la perspectiva ni la experiencia con
este tipo de material
es una cuestión de sed de riesgo de
fascinación por el Titanic a pesar de
todas las advertencias 28 personas
visitaron los restos del transatlántico
a bordo del controvertido sumergible el
año pasado
Pakistán guardó luto nacional por las
víctimas del naufragio de un pesquero
frente a las costas de Grecia según la
ONU es posible que hubiera hasta 750
migrantes a bordo muchos de ellos de
nacionalidad pakistaní entre 200 y 300
según los medios locales 10 personas han
sido detenidas en el país por su
presunta implicación en el tráfico de
personas el siguiente es un informe de
shazai
al menos 20 de las víctimas del
naufragio de la semana pasada eran de la
ciudad de burlan walla tres de ellas
vivían en esta calle amirmalik es primo
de una de las víctimas
el 9 de junio embarcó hacia Italia pocos
días después ocurrió este accidente
por el momento no sabemos oficialmente
si Murió o sobrevivió Esta es la última
nota de voz que le dejó muy
batalla
recibí esta nota de voz el 9 de junio
embarcó en Libia
una vez que llegó a Libia Los
contrabandistas le quitaron el teléfono
no tuvimos más remedio que confiar en el
contrabandista para ponernos en contacto
con él así nos enteramos de que no iba a
viajar a Europa en avión sino
ilegalmente en barco
moschin nos dijo estoy Atrapado No tengo
más remedio que seguirles
6.400 euros fue la cantidad que pagó a
sus contrabandistas para llegar a Europa
sus padres tuvieron que vender su casa
para pagar el viaje unos metros más
abajo en la misma calle otra familia
llora un pariente desaparecido en el
naufragio moniza no tiene noticias de su
hijo akmir
padre de una niña de un año
mi hijo me hizo esta pregunta antes de
irse dime mamá Cómo puedo sobrevivir
aquí los pañales son muy caros la leche
es cara no tengo dinero para alimentar a
mis hijos y luego están las facturas de
Electricidad y gas en todas las familias
los jóvenes están desesperados suplican
a sus padres que vendan la casa para
poder irse a trabajar al extranjero
en Pakistán hay cada vez más gente
planteándose emigrar la inflación de los
últimos años y la crisis política ha
asumido a gran parte de la población en
la desesperación en México una sequía
devastadora ha dejado al descubierto las
ruinas de una iglesia que Data de siglos
atrás los turistas ya pueden visitar el
lugar pero los efectos de dicha sequía
han sido duros para la población como lo
muestra el siguiente informe de nuestros
colegas
En medio de este lago Aquí están los
delicados arcos de una iglesia mexicana
de unos 400 años de antigüedad que nos
sumergirá tras la construcción de una
presa en la década de 1960 pero las
sequías recurrentes de los últimos años
han hecho visible sus ruinas al público
que ahora puedes subir a ella sentarse e
incluso comprar comida Los Pescadores
locales es un pequeño Consuelo para Los
Pescadores que se vieron afectados por
la sequía sus instalaciones no son inmu
los cambios que está sufriendo el lago
lo que es la corriente lo que hace que
se quiebran y al quebrarse ya el pescado
se va como consecuencia del descenso del
nivel del agua Los Pescadores vieron
reducirse en gran medida la cantidad de
peces que pescan esto comenzó de marzo
ya como cinco meses que comenzó a bajar
la presa a bajar a bajar a bajar a bajar
hasta ahorita donde estamos y sigue
bajando sigue bajando la plaza la
iglesia reapareció por primera vez en
2015 ya como consecuencia de la sequía
en este momento se podía visitar en
lancha desde entonces la situación
climática en México ha empeorado
Muchas gracias por seguir un nuevo
episodio de corresponsales nos damos
cita la próxima semana siga con más
información en France 24 y France 24.com